[Applaudissements]
si je suis
c'est à cause d'une copie d'examen mal
rangés dans un cartable
quand j'étais adolescent je répare et où
dans la maison je faisais des cartes
électroniques
bref mon trajet professionnel était tout
tracé je serai ingénieur électronicien
vient le jour du concours à l'école de
référence pas très loin sur le plateau
épreuve d'électronique coefficient 8
je rentre chez moi satisfait j'ouvre mon
cartable
j'y trouve une copie la 6e intercalaires
celle que j'ai tellement mal écrite que
j'ai prise pour un brouillon celle que
je n'ai jamais rendu j'ai raté l'entrée
à l'école que je visais de 1 point sur
500 c'est ce jour là que mon trajet
professionnel à changer d'orientation
je ne serai pas électronicien mais
opticiens et aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler de la lumière et de la résonance
et nous allons jouer avec ça en
commençant par si vous pensez à un
résonance
le mot peut faire référence à un signal
qui revient à un écho vers vous regardez
ces deux objets du quotidien que vous
connaissez une lampe de poche et un
pointeur laser
ces deux objets sont deux sources de
lumière elles ont un comportement très
différents et pourtant au coeur de ces
deux objets il ya là même le même
générateur de lumière qu'on appelle une
diode 7 diodes l on voit la lumière dans
toutes les directions
c'est pour ça qu'on s'en sert pour
s'éclairer les rayons se propage en
ligne droite
imaginez que je mette sept diodes à
l'intérieur d'une boîte une boîte
constitué de deux miroirs en face à face
les rayons se propage dans toutes les
directions
sorte de la boîte sauf lorsqu'il
rencontre un obstacle
quand il rencontre un obstacle ils sont
comme dans un jeu de pong jeux pas si
vous connaissez je la mets c'est
peut-être le seul jeu que les parents
connaissent mieux que les enfants
en tout cas le résultat qui m'intéresse
moi c'est que les seuls rayons qui sont
capables de faire des allers-retours
multiples sont ceux qui sont
rigoureusement sur l'axé formé par les
deux miroirs et c'est pour ça que vous
obtenez un signal comme sa forme et d'un
seul rayon et qui fait ça directivité de
la même manière qu'on dit d'un un
argumentaire formé de plusieurs idées
qu'il est cohérent lorsque les idées
vent dans la même direction
les spécialistes appellent ça de la
lumière cohérente
pourquoi est-ce que c'est utile et bien
vous savez peut-être que le plateau de
saclay où nous sommes à la fin de cette
année sera le premier territoire 100%
fibre et la fibre c'est celle là c'est
celle que vous avez chez vous et vous
imaginez facilement qu'il est nettement
plus facile d'injecter de la lumière
lorsqu'on a un faisceau très directif
que lorsqu'on a une lampe de poche parce
que c'est un fait un tube de verre
extrêmement petit et la façon dont on en
voit vos emails vos vidéos toutes vos
données
et bien en fait c'est simplement en
transmettant la lumière sous forme de 0
et de 1 lorsque la lumière est allumée
c'est 1 1 lorsqu'elle est éteinte c'est
1-0 alors la lumière c'est bien mais la
fibre pourquoi est ce que les six
intéressante c'est parce que elle et
c'est un milieu transparent normal c'est
du verre elle a un taux
d'affaiblissement de 4% seulement ça
veut dire que si vous en voyez sans
grains de lumière vous en récupérer 96
après un kilomètre ce qui est imbattable
pourtant si vous faites deux kilomètres
le coefficient d'affaiblissement sera 0
96 x 0 96 3 km 0 96 soit 0,96 soit 0,87
si vous voulez traverser l'océan eh bien
ça fera 0,96 puissance 6000 si vous avez
une calculatrice qui a la capacité de
faire ce calcul tout ne le peuvent pas
vous rendrez compte que ça fait 0 0 0 0
0 1 107 0 pour vous donner une idée de
ce que ça représente un tel coefficient
d'atténuation essayez d'imaginer que je
vais récupérer 1
seul photon un seul grain de lumière
après une propagation sur 6000 km eh
bien il me faudra injecter dans la fibre
des milliards de milliards de fois
l'énergie de l'univers vous allez me
dire les gergy d'univers je la connais
pas bien c'est pas si grave
la fibre alors à fondue bien avant et
pourtant vous êtes capable de
transporter de l'information de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique de converser avec
des gens qui sont aux états unis par
exemple comment fait-on et bien une
nouvelle fois c'est la résonance qui
vient à notre secours
une résonance différentes une résonance
lorsqu'on dit de 2,2 vibrations qu'elles
sont raisonnante c'est qu'elles sont
d'accord
imaginez que la lumière soit en accord
avec une vibration dans la matière la
fibre et qui ensuite c'est soit capable
de la rétrocéder à la lumière eh bien
c'est ce qui peut se passer
monsieur ce que vous avez déjà entendu
parler derby hommes madame non plus ce
n'est pas un matériau qu'on trouve dans
les magasins de bricolage et pourtant il
est essentiel dans le monde d'internet
d'aujourd'hui c'est un matériau qui
suffit d'injecter dans le vert en
petites quantités il aura la propriété
de vibrer d'accepter la vibration que va
lui fournir une source de lumière
intense
on dira qu'il va devenir excité et du
coup le signal qui s'est propagée qui si
affaibli va avoir la propriété de
profiter de cette énergie acquis
l'erbium va lui rétrocéder du coup un
photon va devenir deux photons devons
devenir 4 et ainsi de suite pour
retrouver retrouver le niveau d'énergie
initial si vous mettez un tel composant
qui fait que quelques mètres tous les 50
ou 100 km eh bien vous atteignez
facilement votre destination
alors maintenant que vous allez me
demander quelle est l'énergie qu'il faut
pour transmettre
allez prenons un cas extrême la totalité
des données transmises en europe pour
joindre des correspondants aux états
unis pendant une heure eh bien il vous
faudra à peu près l'énergie contenue
dans une dizaine de langues de poche
comme celle là pas plus
voyez que la résonance est très utile
voyons maintenant un ou une autre forme
de résonance extrêmement différente
quand on pense aux résonances
étymologiquement ça veut dire re sonné
ça veut dire vibrer plusieurs fois je
voudrais qu'on fasse un test ensemble je
voudrais que vous m'imaginez comme
rockstar la rockstar vous êtes venus
voir et je voudrais que vous me le
disent y est
merci merci je ne méritais pas tant je
n'en méritait pas tant
est-ce que vous avez bien senti le
moment où cet épisode où vous
applaudissez de manière aléatoire et
finalement les vibrations n'ont aucune
relation entre elle et ensuite lorsque
vous avez tous applaudi de manière
synchrone au même rythme
vous avez vu cet effet d'ampleur cet
effet d'amplification c'est ça la
résonance et lorsque ça marche aussi
pour la lumière si la lumière la lumière
si vous étiez capable d'utiliser un
microscope pour regarder extrêmement
finement ce qu'il ya dans un rayon vous
verriez une vague donc une vibration et
donc si on s'intéresse à comment les
vibrations s'ajoutent et qu on le fait
de manière non coordonnée et bien on
obtient une vibration qui ajuste une
ampleur qui augmente très légèrement en
fonction du nombre de deux faisceaux que
l'on ajoute au contraire si l'on fait
très attention de faire en sorte que les
vibrations s'imbriquent les unes dans
les autres et bien vous trouvez les
faits d'amplification vous avez tous
vécu en amplifiant en applaudissant
simultanément ce cas est un cas qui nous
permet donc de retrouver une addition
cohérente de vibrations vous m'avez
suivi
si vous avez j'ai bien précisé et vous
l'avez senti qu'il faut tout ce que vous
applaudissez avec le même rythme
lorsqu'on parle de lumière et de
fréquences c'est la couleur qui
détermine c'est le niveau de vibrations
et la périodicité de ces vibrations
si on veut que toutes les vibrations
s'encastre eh bien il faut absolument
qu'ils aient une seule couleur lorsque
vous accumulez toutes les couleurs et
bien cet effet de l'addition de
vibration ne peut être que incohérente
pourquoi est-ce que ça peut nous être
utile et bien j'aurais pu reprendre le
pointeur laser ici et vous rappeler
comment est ce qu'on a fait pour obtenir
un faisceau lumineux aussi intense on
s'est non seulement préoccupé la
directivité du faisceau mais ont aussi
fait en sorte que dans les allers
retours que la lumière fait à
l'intérieur de cette boîte
et bien chaque aller-retour s'encastre
rigoureusement dans tous les précédents
mais comme ça ne peut marcher qu'avec
une seule couleur et bien la boîte fait
aussi office office de filtre
c'est à dire que la lumière qui était au
départ blanche et blanches ça veut pas
dire une couleur ça veut dire la somme
de toutes les couleurs et bien lorsqu'on
regarde toutes les couleurs il en
restera qu'une toutes les couleurs qui
ne sont pas celles qui sont raisonnante
vont être éliminés
et c'est pour ça que vous avez un laser
extrêmement pur d'une couleur verte
s'il avait choisi une boîte d'une taille
différente eh bien j'ai retenu une autre
couleur et c'est très pratique dans un
système de télécommunications optiques
parce qu'il suffit de démultiplier le
nombre de couleurs pour démultiplier le
nombre de destinataires ce qui est bien
c'est que ça marche en sens inverse une
fois qu'on a fait cet exercice on a
besoin d'extraire les couleurs et on
utilise la même boîte
on va voir si on a cent couleurs on va
voir s'emboîtent de tailles différentes
pour exr chacune d'une couleur
différente
vous avez donc vu que la résonance nous
permet de construire réseaux télécoms
complet et c'est là que revient
l'histoire de la copie oublié il ya dix
ans nous étions huit chercheurs à
quelques kilomètres d'ici
en quête de la solution pour continuer à
tenir le choc de l'augmentation du débit
dans les fibres optiques et nous avons
une idée traditionnellement lorsqu'on
fait la somme de deux faisceaux on
obtient un faisceau qui est deux fois
plus lumineux c'est même ça qu'on
exploite dans la résonance
et si au lieu de faire l'addition
constructive de ses deux faisceaux ont
faisais l'addition destructive en maths
on appellerait ça une soustraction
c'est quand même beaucoup moins joli
qu'une addition destructive et en fait
ça traduit le fait que on est capable de
faire des interférences les
interférences et la possibilité lorsque
vous sommet deux faisceaux d'obtenir une
absence de faisceaux c'est à dire une
absence de lumière
c'est une autre façon codée
l'information sociale est plus
simplement d' allumer et éteindre à
faisceau laser mais c'est de jouer avec
une autre méthode
une autre propriété de la lumière
contrôler son état vibratoire
cette technique que nous avons
développée est devenu un standard de
l'industrie elle a permis de
démultiplier la capacité d'un facteur 10
dans le monde entier elle représente
aujourd'hui 12 milliards d'équipements
de chiffre d'affaires dans le monde
entier installées chaque année vous
l'avez même utiliser et je pense en
particulier à ce que j'ai perdu lorsque
j'ai parlé du jeu vidéo tout à l'heure
et qui depuis que j'en ai parlé sont en
train de naviguer sur internet pour
trouver de quoi je parlais est ce que
c'est la fin de ce mariage entre
l'optique et la cohérence probablement
pas imaginez un monde où la fibre serait
capable de lire son environnement
acoustique d'être sensible à ce qui se
passe autour d'elle par exemple une
pelleteuse qui passeraient qui serait la
fibre sera informé avant même que quel
soit coupé de ce qui se passe ou des
voitures qui passeraient sur le plateau
de saclay qu'on pourrait compter pour
réguler le trafic
c'est résonance là c'est celle que nous
préparons pour le futur vous avez
compris que j'ai failli manquer cette
jolie aventure
il s'en est fallu de très peu il s'en
est fallu de sept minutes d'inattention
ou j'ai mal rangé cette copie sept
minutes ou une science que je ne
connaissais pas c'est ouvert à moi et 6
7 minutes pour vous c'était ici et
maintenant
merci
[Applaudissements]